welcome to the global roundtable this
series focuses on the future of economic
competition my name is parag khanna i'm
joined by a distinguished panel
including gumby samoy Oh Daniel Altman
and uninsured hollows today we're going
to be talking about rebuilding America
in the 21st century this was a major
theme in Obama's presidential campaign
and it's also been a big theme in
Congress however Congress is very much
deadlocked over this so how do we dig
ourselves out of this hole pardon the
pun it's a great question right because
we've been neglecting important
investments in our economy for decades
now investments in education
infrastructure and high value-added
research all the things that the
president outlined in a state of the
union address and how we going to make
this shift into spending money on these
things when we're facing enormous
deficits we need a massive change in our
spending patterns we are trying to be
the world's policeman at the same time
as pay for massive pensions we need to
shift spending and we need to restore
our saving culture so we're the ones
paying for it in the long term as well
there's a problem that I see making
getting in the way of that happening
which is if a single American building
anywhere in the world is blown up by
anybody the whole country will mobilize
to deal with that issue we will
sacrifice anything we will send people
where we need to go we'll spend whatever
money to put those people to justice
find them prevent it what's happening to
infrastructure is this very different
kind of war but it's it's a war of its
own kind it's kind of creaking and
disintegration of the society but it has
no similar response and Obama tried the
kind of almost Marshall and 911 like
consensus in the State of the Union I'm
fixing it but I don't think you ever
will no one realizes how grave it is in
a way aren't the deficit Buster's and
Congress completely wrong that we should
be freezing spending even though these
are such vital initiatives because in
fact our deficit as enormous as it is
our debt is really so large so many
trillions of dollars that it's not even
a number it's more of just a concept and
what foreign creditors are looking to
see is not can the United States repay
tomorrow or the next day but rather are
we building an economic base line and a
foundation that will have the capacity
to repay in the future therefore these
are
necessary investments is that is that
wrong I think you're absolutely right
but we have to again shift the spending
so that we are spending in on things
that will increase our ability to repay
in the future we have to invest in the
long-term potential of the economy to
grow if you look at discretionary
spending in Washington a lot of that
money is not doing this and we need to
move to the areas that do it's been a
big change over the last 20 years moving
away from them we need to take it back
how about the charter companies the 19th
century model the Carnegie's the
Rockefellers these major corporations
that really built the railroads the
United States through public-private
partnerships why don't we do that again
well I think that most people look
around most private investors look
around and say way too much uncertainty
lack of clarity on taxes lack clarity
and industrial policy in the United
States for sure and that does not give
private investors the sort of comfort
that they need to invest in these areas
we've seen Warren Buffett make large
pledges into the private sector over the
past 18 months and I think you would see
much more that if people felt that the
government was really serious about
creating an environment where people
would get their returns back I think one
of the things that's distressing when
you see a place like China we always
emphasize the political system of the
human rights abuses of the jasmine
revolution we all of which is important
but they are doing real making real
investments to make people's kind of
daily lives incrementally better by the
week in a way that we've just forgotten
to do and asking ourselves in a kind of
very deep way why is it that our
political system is unable to be
responsive to people's everyday needs in
a way that an authoritarian system is is
a very serious question well we can Envy
the authoritarian system for its ability
to make big investments in plan for the
long term but the fact is there's very
little accountability in that system and
so if you think that there would be
wasted in a project that politicians
declare that they're going to invest in
here there's an enormous amount of
wastage going on in these authoritarian
regimes too and they will eventually pay
the price for that as well so we do all
agree that we have to invest in our
infrastructure and that it's not going
to be perfect there's a lot of
uncertainty but there's an equal amount
of uncertainty in authoritarian
societies like China where they make
lots of investments but there is in fact
a lot of corruption as well so but there
is a consensus that we have to rebuild
so with that thanks for your insights
and
more on that in relevant topics at big
thing calm